I'm really excited to talk to you, and I'm
going to get started by introducing myself.
My name is Max, and I'm a developer, and I'm
an artist, and my day job is that like lime
a user-experience engineer.
That basically means that I'm an engineer
and build things and it's directly informed
with the way that the user perceives it, and
by the effect that it has on them and their
perceptions.
I also really love websites, particularly
websites which are like useless or weird.
I think those are the most fun thing that
you can build on a computer.
I'm talking today about building inter active
experiences with WebAssembly, and I have to
level with you before we start that this talk
is a little bit like a Trojan horse situation,
so I lured you into the stands with a promise
of exciting web technology like WebAssembly
but I'm really going to talk to you about
my favourite things which are falling sand
games, so I hope that's not a problem!
So, if you hasn't heard of falling sand games,
they are kind of this whole genre of web games
like free flash applet kind of things where
you have a palette of pixelated elements - pixelated
phenomenon.
They interactor with each other and cool things
happen.
They share a lot in common with Conway's Game
of Life, and, in particular, they have the
same kind of really cool behaviour behaviour
where you have simple rules, and when you
let those play out, you get really amazing
complex emergent behaviour.
It can be really surprising to even the person
maybe who set up those rules and certainly
the person watching them play out, because
you could never expect exactly what you would
get just based on reading that it does this,
and these conditions are that.
It's much more complex.
Another thing I love about sand games is they
have a low fidelity visual representation
of what is happening on screen.
You have a couple of coloured pixels maybe
moving around a little bit but there is so
little to go off, that it lets your imagination
run wild and interpret what you're seeing
with its own layer over what is going on,
so you see something much more vivid in your
mind's eye than what is going on in the screen,
and there is a lot of room to play with that,
and that's really fun.
So many people oftentimes ask when they see
these games like how do you win this game?
There is no win condition or score or anything
like that.
The way the games work is that you're making
your own objectives as you play, and that's
part of the game.
Oftentimes, that means understanding what
is going on in front of you, so maybe you're
trying to figure out how a new element works,
or how it interacts with another one.
You might make a hypothesis about what happens,
make an experiment and test it out, or maybe
you will be like telling yourself a story,
and playing it out with the elements in front
of you, and seeing what happens and imagining
your mind, and so on, and so I think it's
really wonderful mode of play, and it is one
where you're not only the player, but literatures
kind of a story-teller for yourself.
So my favourite falling sand game has been
for a long game called the Powder Game.
And it kind of has this really interesting
feature which is that when you make things
in it, right in the game, in the menu, you
can upload them, and they go to a server,
and other people can browse them and see them.
It's got this long-standing weird and thriving
community of people building interesting things,
and uploading them for each other.
And it's really cool to see, given like just
these small tools, the kind of things that
people make for each other to play with.
So you've got like your bog standard is thousands
and thousands of volcanos.
You know, it's like an infinite fourth grade
science fair of different volcanos, but they're
cool, and I can see why people want to make
volcanoes.
People make different destructible structures
so you can load it into your browser and then
have fun setting it on fire, or pouring acid
on it, and that is like a fun way to play
with somebody who you've never met.
People get really creative.
There are all kinds of games that people make
out of the simple elements they have like
mood rings, and you can see this one says
it is clear it won't be accurate of your mood
unless you first vote.
There is a lot of vote-pandering in these
communities.
It's a staple of how they communicate, but
this is a cool game that somebody made inside
another game.
My personal favourite type of sand game upload
is this entire genre called Don't Smoke where
it displays to you anatomical phenomenon that
will that will happen if you smoke a cigarette,
like the lava will travel up and explode your
brain.
These games are awesome.
You can see why I was fascinated with them
for my entire childhood.
As I get older and first learned to programme,
as soon as I could run two for loops together,
I knew I wanted to build a falling sand game
- the best one of, obviously!
I knew a bit of JavaScript and knew how to
use an API, and I looked at other sand games
and how they were working and what the elements
were doing had they were moving around, and
when I was re-implement ing them, I found
they are really simple, and, with just a couple
of low numbers of hundreds of lines of JavaScript,
I suddenly had water moving around the screen.
I was really excited, and I was having so
much fun, but I realised that as I kept adding
new elements to the game, it was getting slower
and slower, and I didn't have a very firm
grasp on concepts such as like functions,
or having your code in more than one file,
and what I was manifesting was as I was adding
more features into this big blob of code,
everything was getting more and more buggy.
You can see this blob on the right-hand side
of the screen was an element that was a mistake
I made decided to domesticate and keep in
the game as the given element.
I couldn't understand what was going on any
more.
So I was okay, I'm going to have to do, refactor
this code somehow and make it good.
I didn't know exactly what that meant but
I knew I needed to be in different tiles,
so I had to set up webpack so I could have
different JavaScript files.
This is the last commit I made to the project
in 2015.
Used webpack for my pending factor which never
happened.
I think this is a common story.
So some time went by, and I got a cat.
I moved to California.
But other things were going on in my life
but I was still thinking about sand games,
and I was noticing a lot of cool projects
that were happening that were letting people
build and code in the browser, and kind of
make programme one element of a larger system.
I thought that was really cool.
So I had this idea that I got excited about
last year which is what if there was a falling
sand game where people could code their own
elements and upload them, and then all those
elements by different people could interact,
and there could be reactions that nobody ever
anticipated, and something could happen?
So I kind of knew that I needed a different
architecture diagram for my game rather than
having anything in one file and one blog,
if people needed to write code, there would
be separation to an engine and maybe the different
elements, and I was maybe inspired by things
like React and I thought okay, there can be
an API that they talk over, and be the framework,
and then the components.
But I also knew that if I wanted people to
actually code and upload their elements, there
would need to be a pleasant and easy experience,
and I don't need to handle as many of the
edge cases as I could for them.
I started to prototype this and trying to
move the gross logic out of the elements and
make them as easy and fun to make and make
the engine, if it had to be gross, that was
fine.
I was really happy with this prototype and
I was having so much fun building elements
in it, I was having a great time thought I
want to keep doing it and if I know anything
about if you want someone to use your thing,
it's got to be on the web as far as I'm concerned,
and so I wanted to start over and build it
so that I could actually share it with people.
So that kind of turned into Sand Spiel.
The rest of my talk is boring, if you want
to do that for the next ten minutes, I'm not
going to judge you!
So, but I will give you a quick demo so you
can see what it looks like.
I will press play.
You've got your different elements.
I will plant some flowers.
And then I think that people then set everything
on fire, but it's okay.
Doesn't release any carbon!
So, that's kind of what the game looks like,
and you can see there is this canvas where
the simulation is happening, and there is
the buttons and the UI.
So, the one of the things that I found when
I was building Sand Spiel that turned out
to be critical and helped me to build it was
that I decided to try to use WebAssembly.
So there is actually WebAssembly in this talk,
I'm sorry.
I've said that word a couple of times now,
maybe you've heard it this week, but just
to, like, rehash, WebAssembly is not really
a language it's an instruction format that
you compile instructions to and has properties
that people are excited about.
First of all, it's fast, so I'm not going
to go into detail here because this is kind
of any kind of performance conversation, but
particular ly it is, if you have a lot - it's
predictable what the performance will be.
With JavaScript, you can make it fast, but
you are relying on the way that it gets optimised,
and you need to write it in a very careful
way, whereas with WebAssembly, there are much
less moving pieces, and, if you write it in
a certain way, you know it will be fast on
everybody's browser.
Another important aspect of WebAssembly is
that it is sandboxed.
So it is safe in WebAssembly to run code written
by someone who you don't necessarily trust
on your machine, or even on your user's machine
sometimes, and it's not going to steal their
passwords necessarily because it's sandboxed.
It can't reach into the rest of the system
like some native code can.
I thought this was going to be an important
thing for my of the game because I thought
I was going to be running people's code they
wrote, and running it on other people's computers,
but it turns out I never got to that part.
That was ambitious.
In the future, this will come in handy, but
just the other factors of WebAssembly were
useful to me.
Lastly, I want to let people know that it
really is ready to use.
I was surprised for this myself, but, you
know, like four major browsers and some other
ones as well have already implemented it.
It works also like a mobile really well, and
I was, I'm surprised by how fast it's moving
and the spec is pragmatic and informed by
what browsers I we already have as far as
structure, and there is a lot of - it so is
it is becoming something that you can ship.
And I had no problems with compatibility,
surprisingly, with WebAssembly.
One more thing about it being ready to use
is that the tooling is, at least in my experience,
was really good.
I wrote some Rust code for Sand Spiel that
was compiled to WebAssembly.
The entire tool chain that I used to do that,
including tools like Wasm and Pack, which
let you respect ively compile Rust code into
a JavaScript file that loads it, and a tool
for kind of calling in between from WebAssembly
and JavaScript, these tools are still like
in beta but nice to use.
There is a lot of shared culture and shared
communication norms within the JavaScript
community and the Rust assembly community.
If you have expectations about how a library
should work and how a documentation should
be and what sort of error messages it should
give you that you're used to from writing
JavaScript, go you go to write Rust in WebAssembly,
you won't be shocked or horrifies because
it's a lot of the same people.
They have the same expectations you do of
what a good user interface is for a tool.
This was really great, and I appreciate being
able to use this.
Another really critical thing about that I
want to tell you about the way that you can
use WebAssembly is that you don't have to
write your whole application in it and it
happens to run in the browser and it's just
a big hunk of Rust or something.
My app is 50 per cent JavaScript and about
50 per cent Rust WebAssembly.
This was awesome because I got to put the
things that needed to run many, many times
a second, and be really fast.
I got to write that in Rust and make it fast.
Then all the things that don't need to be
fast because it's just like, you know, building
user interface, or triggering a network request,
all those things I got to write?
JavaScript and benefit from the fact that
JavaScript is really good at doing these - and
also that I got to use the whole ecosystem
of React in different tools made this really
awesome.
If I had tried to write the whole thing in
Rust, it would have taken longer because it's
like there's no good tools right now for building
interfaces yet, not like the way there are
in JavaScript, and so being able to split
my concerns here was really awesome.
I think you can kind of imagine like the JavaScript
code here is most ly just, you know, React
code like you may have seen before, and the
way it interacts with Rust, is that essentially,
there is a gist-like class that has some functions,
and - and from the respect of the, it, you're
calling the JavaScript functions.
I have a paint method which will draw a circle
on to the screen in a certain element in a
certain radius, or I have one to reset the
canvas, or to calculate a simulation.
From the JavaScript perspective, you're really
just calling some methods and it happens to
be implemented in WebAssembly which is fast.
That is some of the tools like I mention before.
So, as for the WebAssembly code, it looks
like this tick method which ones one frame
per simulation.
I will show you how it works.
This is by the way what powers this part of
the game, where the pixels are moving around
and interacting.
So essentially, I have a data structure which
is like a big two dimensional array of all
the data for my different cells of the grid,
and it goes through, loops through each one
in order, and, when it gets to each one, it
runs an update function based on whatever
the type is of the grid itself, and so you
get to the third one, and it's a sand grid.
It's a piece of sand, so it matches to the
sand update function, and the sand update
function is really simple.
It's like an if-else statement, and the way
that that works is it it looks at its local
co-ordinate system and says what is the cell
below me?
What is the type of that?
If it is empathy, then I can fall down, and
I will just go down there, and I will erase
myself and rate myself one pixel lower.
If that first check failed and there is a
piece of stone underneath you, then it goes
to the second statement, and it checks one
of the diagonals and tries to fall there.
And it does the same thing.
So that is all there is to this algorithm
that lets you do the sand, and kind of the
trick here is that it is happening on every
pixel of the grid, and it is happening at
60 frames a second, and it starts to look
like how you would imagine sand would work.
So there is, like, 18 other elements, and
some are a little more complicated but they
have the same pattern of they're a single
function, they call some APIs to read anywhere
neighbours and to write to their neighbours,
and then you get different behaviour.
So, I mentioned this earlier, but it really
was like the key to being to make this project
quickly, the fact that I could put things
in WebAssembly that needed to be fast and
I could implement everything else in JavaScript,
and use the ecosystem, and not have to worry
about all the type-checking and all of the
other conditions that Rust enforces on your
code that can sometimes slow you down, and,
so another thing that I mentioned is the network
code which is I also build like an upload
and download functionality that I really liked,
and so this has been the most gratifying part
of the project, so, a lot of - it's pretty
much middle-schoolers, but a lot of middle-schoolers
play this game and draw amazing things.
They ignore the fact that there is a simulation
attacked and use it like MS Paint and not
blocked in their computer lab which is maybe
why they use it, but they draw awesome stuff,
and it's fun to see what they do.
I think like maybe one of the - so the most
popular, there's an upvoting system and the
most liked and loved post is this puppy.
I can't explain it, but I also loved this
puppy.
There is fan art and people remixing her and
drawing her in different situation.
On the right, that's Super Duna Luna, the
tall one.
In the Powder Game, there was a rule against
load ing somebody else's submission.
We encourage forking in Sand Spiel which leads
to this fun stuff.
Unfortunately, I mentioned that the best part
of the project has been seeing the things
that people upload, but it's also been the
worst part of the project as well.
Not everybody is nice, and there is like,
I moderate the posts every morning and waking
up to it is not always fun.
Sometimes, I feel like this person where I
feel like these people are ruining the game,
and I wish it had never been created so none
of it would happen.
And so I do do some manual moderation, but
it's really not sustainable, and I'm not sure
what to do, and so I've kind of, like, looked
to where I look for to solve problems when
I have programming problems, and they've not
been useful, like, there's no algorithm that
would be nice for making people be nice to
each other on the internet.
Not even like string-matching algorithms work,
I tried.
And like, nor do other places where who have
usually solved my tough programming problems,
like CSS tricks, they have no button that
will make people be nice to each other, unfortunately.
This is a problem I still have.
I haven't solved it, and I know there are
people who have problems like this, and I'm
definitely curious to hear what they did or
if they're just like there's all this invisible
work that happened behind the scenes that
made it look like things are nice.
I definitely would be interested to talk if
you think you know a solution.
Please do not tell me to use a neural network!
Thank you!
So, please do, I think we have a break after
that, so please play with Sand Spiel if you
want to kill some time and chill out.
I have a longer form blog post that goes into
more of the inspiration for the game and some
of the design decisions, and also into some
of the technical details because I glossed
over some things.
Thank you so much!
[Cheering and applause].